[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'ailleurs les séries avant que khalid
et martin bonhomie et monitorer gallen
oui c'est pas toi mais je vais résister
à ses supporters de mes rêves lui toi la
bleue toi t'as pas mais on est quatre à
dire à tous les taxis là ils nous
regardent qui nous écoutent ou qu'ils
entendent parler on les veut tous devant
le studio mais voilà comment commence
les problèmes ou les taxis devant le
studio et on leur offrira des places où
sortira vous verrez et on ira l'entrée
des places c'est pour toi c'est cadeau
c'est pas en gas turbine
c'est son cadeau merci tout va bien
bienvenue dans le 45e
mettez vous à l'aise devant les portiers
pour une petite dizaine de minutes
tranquillement n'hésitez pas à mettre 5
étoiles à la fin du trajet se fait
toujours plaisir
on commence avec les 24 heures télé
qu'est ce que c'est c'est tout ce qui
s'est passé à la télé aujourd'hui genre
très vite que son équipe souffre
regardez
[Musique]
encore en fait qu'un carnet rose suis
pas l'homme le roi du rock et balouches
pédaler de l'arête du maquereau dont eu
un enfant ensemble on la retrouve à la
téloche excuse et grandi et travaillé au
milieu des animaux est décidée à garder
la foi dans le gouffre en place le film
du samedi de canal penser à changer le
landais complète de gaulle ça prête à
confusion quand tu oses habitués ont
changé en pet programme d'habitude c'est
le film adulte 1 le premier sera au
rythme là on venus les 18 trous
d'augusta ça vous voir ici la saison le
masters d'augusta si je dors à 13h
jean-pierre pernaut et nous avons près
qu'ils mangent et après son jt je vais
enquête mais il boit avant visiblement
d'abord encore cette semaine notre patte
série matrimoine gastronomie sportive
digne du sacro-saint des prolos
j'attends bien celle là
et comme il est avec nous se sent petit
plaisir best-of des moments les plus
saines de redémarrer quand l'om perd un
match aussi votre comme des merdes a
pris le clac aussi flashy la tête ça
valait mieux arrêter de nous faire chier
ce que des gueules les a demandé
ailleurs et avec ses poses augmente pas
normal
à découvrir ci-dessus d'avoir l'avis de
rené sur tout ce qui s'est passé à la
télé franchement j'attends avec
impatience qu'on va être pas mal on va
être pas mal du tout la dre sable mâle
et combattent pas bon la comédien dans
l'équipe a quand même fait le sort des
gazaouis
c'est aux motards ah ben oui c est ça le
plus en plus on lance la carrière de
mokhtar c'est le buzz jouer dans tous
les films d'action les cas on a montré
qu'il peut jouer mon petit annick déjà
elle peut faire de là qu il peut faire
plein de choses mais dans le film
d'action il est incroyable on l'a mis
dans des grands films d'action lamy dans
le comment on appelle le transporteur
voulons fudan et de couscous fast and
furious des trucs comme ça vous allez
voir il donne la réplique c'est
incroyable on dirait qu'il est dans le
film c'est le meilleur casting qu'on
pouvait faire pour la suite
francky n'avait pas des devoirs ce soit
devant moi j'ai rarement dans ta jolie
là
devriez rentrer les faire mais c'est pas
mal
ah excusez moi je suis en train de garer
la voiture de céréales ou non certains
croquis
quand j'étais au lycée c'est de là que
partent et les courses
tesco l'histoire
tu as la voie ferrée qui coupe la route
à exactement 400 m ici
vers je passais à voir le train vas-y
vas-y toi sois pas triste de grève
ça devient avocat super n'est pas brisé
compères bien bonjour il joue super bien
c'est un taxi si ces joutes d'en bas non
non ahmat mais toi tu as changé non mais
t'es saignements fourguer delormeau ben
justement ne croit pas si bien dire de
leur moi je vois dans lac-saint-louis en
est à l'heure il a joué dans le taxi
cinq de leurs mots vous montrerez ça
tout à leur erp bond à 7 ans il a dit
j'ai pas pris ma décision
si pendant sept à huit coeurs leur
adaptateur jeu 64 ans d'un hôtel qui
accueille des nouveaux touristes mais tu
sens que le punch de bienvenue il n'a
pas versé à côté il te parle de la vie
n'est pas net net lui car il vient
régulièrement ici des jeunes et le
week-end à tout va bien voilà voilà
pourquoi ces jolies parce que c'est très
joli
visiblement nostradamus il n'a pas la 4g
il a du mal à rejoindre parce qu'il a
beau tout essayer cadres ont pas une
frappe de royan vous habitez dans une
grande ville oui ils n'auraient d'accord
mais ça veut dire que l'endroit où vous
habitez c'est en ile de france
ça fait partie de l'ile-de-france et
autour de paris quoi d'abord il maîtrise
aussi à la dumas personne s'appelle
comme ça ils achetaient juin vous êtes
les commandes soja alors là si désolée
c'est gratos et ma vidéo préférée du
jour c'est le chien qui comprend qu'il
va tomber du canal et étangs tout pour
s'en sortir mais c'est trop tard les
tombes du canada c'est pas mal on va
voir ça la palette 3d regarder dehors de
soumettre ce tarder à regarder ici dans
le canapé les débuts de glissades et là
dans son regard au centre c'est
l'abandon total et fait partie d'après
les bruits et donald est une supercherie
n'a même jamais passé on peut par an
voire juste le gars qui disent c'est
joli
c'est joli régulièrement ici des jeunes
élevé tout va bien voilà voilà pourquoi
ces jolies parce que c'est très joli
d'ailleurs j'ai allégé et étrangers
aussi international étranger se saouler
du tir au synthé relève en blues on
dirait le michael jackson mais marocain
ça ne rigole pas trop je t'aime plâtres
[Rires]
du mois paris où je veux pas l'être est
bien bourrin parce que oui c'était
qu'ils étaient vraiment choqué la haye
avec nous tu pour lever lunettes et le
chapeau frais on s'est déjà vu maître
gims sans lunettes
[Rires]
tu as déjà vu sa lunette non c est
madame jean jacques audubon garde le
gabon veut regarder soit trop à
l'étranger du japon qu'un manifestant
il hurle ses revendications il ya son
pote de vent qui est complètement bois
c'est une spéciale mais tente de rester
je suis à crédit pendant qu'ils
regardent et aux gâteaux à la série
natif de pont les pieds on te coûter
plus gai
et en forme de chute de 6,1 en espagne
déjà est un homme politique qui a
complètement raté sur l'entrée de débats
dur de se rappeler sa place est énorme
et comme on a aussi vu la plus belle de
tous les temps on est à huit mille
tracts 300 sur l'échelle de leur chômage
elle avait dû ensuite contacter d'au
moins vingt et un pour les sept jours le
début de l'infection
[Musique]
j'ai pas eu au téléphone et on a des
news gérard louvin c'est un dernier
week-end à val d'isère jugé il sait
donner grave à la folie 12 juin si
l'enfant que j'étais là par hasard
la torsion gmat lcd d'état il est prêt
pour d'accepter des fous et gervais bon
soit les deux nouveaux qui enfin tous
les ailleurs les kings 2 action movie
avec mathieu j'ai maté des images un peu
extrême je vous ai fait un cadeau dans
un instant maj extraites des jaquettes
des gars comme la vitesse sur france 3
dans le champion de char à voile ça peut
aller très très vite c'est un peu là lui
sauf que ça reste france 3 donc phase
calme assez rapidement le terrain
champion du monde de char à voile
il enseigne cette discipline sur la
plage de soulac monter à bord c'est bien
un nul suffit pas il est foutu c'est pas
grave si bagnole sans platines pour
dominique chapatte de turbo on s'est
amusé à imaginer si dominique chapatte
intégrer le casting des lignes d'action
notamment taxi c'était technique je suis
en train de rouler quelque chose doit qu
il
facile la voiture se révèle d'une grande
agilité d'une grande facilité de
conduite puis alors quel plaisir quand
on est au volant mais aussi à la face
arrière
cet officier c'est parti je me lance à
l'assaut des artères de la ville
d'autres feux rouges et bouchons
enfin si commode que ça
c'est le bordeaux d'aujourd'hui la ligne
de tramway et au milieu des pieds de
vigne a tout pour être heureux volant de
cette voiture qui est ultra silencieuse
du fait qu'elle est très très bien
insonorisé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je dois parler deux secondes ce qui est
hélas toujours réparer les bêtises aux
médias ouais ouais là on a des comédiens
autour de la drave sûr que ça fasse
appliquer ce carré à points le cac mid &
data chacun mais j'ai un truc à te à te
confier je dois dire d'abord que c'est
franck qui m'a forcé non je m'appelle
pas natation sissi duparc c'est-à-dire
l'actrice qui dit toujours oui
csi téléspectateurs depuis tout à
l'heure il a fait savoir qu'il dit pas
dire bonjour à natacha très bien bonjour
à la passe à dix s appelle la tâche à
aller dire bonjour
natacha dupas voilà donc il est très
content mais c'est comme ça voilà qu
hamid et tuque et kamiar poil ça vient
de faire ça aurait fait pas c'est pas
payant ce jour c'est vrai quoi tu as
beaucoup et abarth d'en haut mais
peut-être en bas
je sais pas
l'hypothèse d'un double attentat
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'amitié c'est d'abord la lituanie
si ça te va
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourquoi l'école salle à la base
de nos michel merde j'ai senti quelque
chose au niveau des cuisses c'est vrai
mais en fin de match aller dans les
films comme dans la ville n'avait pas la
tâche n'a pas fait mais c'est mon double
diabolique monde actrice et sissi duparc
d'accord exactement merci à vous appeler
vous savez madame des grands comédiens
taux de la table ben bouger bernard
farcy ces couacs appelé bernard direct
pour lui dire que tu voulais absolument
dans taxi sans à baho et bien sûr parce
que avec malik ce qu'on voulait faire
c'était ramener notre humour dans
l'ambiance de taxi et puis pour nous le
pilier de l'humour des taxis c'est bien
c'est le connaissait rejouer maintenant
et maintenant mais dans le film dans le
film les plus commissaire il est de voir
des artistes connus maire de marseille
bernard tapie tout de suite oui ou pas
franchement oui parce que on a eu une
conversation très agréable très
décontracté mais en gros définit son
projet mais il était encore en train de
restructurer le scénario et puis quand
j'ai lu
le dc du feeling c'est de dire ça mais
tu as envie de travailler avec avec
cette personne non voilà non mais je le
connaissais pas donc mais quand on a
parlé on sait on en parle très bien
voilà c'est par le biais de téléphones
non mais c'est là il a trouvé les mots
qu'il fallait
il a trouvé son rythme surtout je vais
aller au comédia alors médias dans des
petits trucs passé j'ai regardé les
mystères de l'amour aime bien la tâche
alors ça ça va ça il faut que tu te dis
mon produit encore frère non mais c'est
un génie bosse sur moi il écrit à droite
vous retiendrez qu au moins au moins
fait dire un truc ce soir à 22h55 sur
france 2 oui merci voilà l aile et m6 10
ou quelle belle volée j'ai très vite de
ce matin alors qu amy tu vas on va faire
le bruit et après je me tuerai le petit
groupe parce que je vais te montrer un
extrait de maisons à vendre qui va
passer très bonne si je viens chaîne
préférez aller au kenya - là on va bien
sûr alors regardez bon alors du coup
bayard brut dans votre caste et les gars
de gomorra et coup mais en france aussi
est de gens bourrés de talent bourré
dans vicky sont dispo pour la suite de
taxi notamment les mystères de l'amour
ce week-end à besné qui s'est séparé
tout le monde voulait ce cas c'est tout
le monde veut se casser tu vois pourquoi
culture qu'il soit tu te casses pas
c'est moi qu'on katchalov salut je te
dire je suis vous allez pas menti quand
même dit fait pas bon qu'un trait ses
avocats fils et moins cocasse mais
arrêtez là au stop
assisté à une scène de suicide
surréaliste réalisé par une cascade aux
professionnels j'ai jamais vu ça de vos
nuits calmes toi je me calme est revenu
[Musique]
mais n'ont jamais trop sur ses finitions
et donc pas se fier sur des passes en
avant c'est tout et bam figure est ce
que tu veux je te montre un extrait de
maisons à vendre ce soir franchement à
la moire m'a dit franchement y'a pas
grand chose à la télé ce soir j'ai
regardé ça va regarder regarder mais
sans avancer ce soir m6
c'est en pata sur m6
notre association de bienfaiteurs et à
la proche
la surprise est prometteuse bonjour
comment alors j'ai une petite surprise
je vais emmener quelqu'un qui va vous
mettre de la bonne humeur
[Musique]
vallat mais pas le moral hier et je lui
ai dit je vais t'emmener quelqu'un pour
te donner du moral toits tours à faire
non non non c'est plutôt bricolages home
des collettes bricoler tu sais cela
tisse à 20h50 c'est un batteur nathan
21h salle c'est stable maintenant
ce 4 sur nous 21h10 alors à mi combat
qu'on a mené l'attaqué thème alors